cécile pourquoi avoir fait preuve décidé
de faire une aventure comme ça vous en
aviez marre d'être célibataire parce
qu'on on peut pas croire que vous rester
célibataire si si si si non alors c'est
que vous êtes non parce que c'est pas
possible ou vous êtes très très
difficile où vous habitez ou dans le
désert non mais y'a rien promettre
j'ai eu c'est vrai j'ai été dans un
moment où c'était vraiment le désert
pourquoi parce que j'ai eue de certaines
circonstances de la vie qui ont fait que
j'ai beaucoup été dans le sacrifice par
rapport à ma fille comme vous avez pu le
voir c'est vrai qu'elle est assez cash
elle a un sacré caractère je les ai
toujours élevé c'est bon là d'or c'est
vrai à oujda qui m'ont aussi j'aime
d'amour voilà c'est devenu une star est
aussi alors vous vous êtes donc le marié
ça y est je suis j'ai dans l'émission
oui j'ai été j'ai dit oui alors lors de
cette cérémonie de mariage on
s'attendait à ce que cécile qui est
d'habitude très expressif soit joyeuse
et blagueuse mais en fait pas du tout
elle a eu une petite montée de race
raoui regarder avant de rencontrer un
son nouveau mari n'arrive à amélie
j'ai commencé en fait avoir une espèce
de pression à la poitrine je suis pas
très très bien
j'ai rarement ressenti ce stress là dans
ma vie
j'ai vraiment l' angoisse kiki
[ __ ] j'suis pas je sens mon coeur qui
bat
à mille à l'heure je sens mes mains
tremblaient pour que je suis pas bien
papa j'ai commencé à avoir des
des espèces de deux fourmis de papillons
dans les yeux
j'aime faire un malaise papa
on va dans ce faire
ça va cécile c'est vrai que là bas c'est
normal on va se marier qu'un mec qu'on
le connaît même pas on n'a jamais vu ça
mais on voit alors faut savoir que tout
le long de cette expérience j'ai pas eu
le le stress j'ai pas eu l'angoissé me
suis pas j'ai pas posée je me suis pas
posé de questions je me suis dit voilà
je fais un choix j'assume jusqu'au bout
mais le problème c'est que mon corps en
fête a pris le dessus de votre tête
disait oui votre corps disait non voilà
d'où les fourmis dans les dieux ça ça
fait beaucoup rire les gens mais j'ai eu
une montée de tension et un moment donné
je me suis ressaisi et je me suis dit
non mais si c'est quoi tu tu as toujours
été jusqu'au bout des choses
vas-y foncé et voilà et heureusement que
mon papa était là hostiles
alors ce qui a étonné les
téléspectateurs hier soir c'est que vous
étiez assez froide et distante avec
votre nouveau mari l'air plutôt sympa on
peut suivre ils étaient contents
l'impression et la faim qui fit selon
lui un bon délire regardez n'a pas tout
de suite jusqu'à retenir non c'est pas
ça mais il a un regard d'un malaise en a
bien un strabisme alors si vous voulez
vous embrasser
l amiral direct dans la bouche tu vois
pas coupé voisine nature peinture c'est
très bien ces failles corps on va dire
qu'on n'est pas dans le roman sont
aujourd'hui je m'attendais pas à ça pour
être totalement franc en fait je le
subis sur vous a tout le temps c'est si
long là qu'une fois merci c'est gentil
alors il faut savoir que là quand je
prends le ravioli à pleine bouche n'est
ce pas et que j'ai dit un bon cru voilà
c'est j'ai dit j'ai un truc averses
parce que je partais en itv juste
quelques précisions il faut savoir que
durant ce moment là la mairie le la
réception et cetera
on a commencé avec alain à avoir une
compatibilité une une liens qui se
créent en tulle malheureusement
malheureusement à l'image on ne le voit
pas on me fait passer pour une personne
complètement hautaine et une personne
qui s'en fout complètement de lui géante
est plus dans la protection et dans la
réserve que dans dans le côté je te snob
je te calcule pas là ils ont fait un
montage qui pour moi ne représente
absolument pas ce que j'ai ressenti ce
qu'on a ressenti avec alain et comment
s'est déroulée la corde quand vous avez
vu alain il vous a plu vous pas
physiquement les beaux gosses alors
physiquement la première à bord non
c'est bon non au premier abord
non ouais vous pourriez pas mal
franchement alors ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
plu en lui c'est parce que la beauté
tout est relatif bien sûr voilà ce qui
m'a plu à lui en lui c'est le côté en
fait rassurant la personne qui va
s'inquiéter qui me dit ça va pas trop
stressé il a fait 2 3 blagounette il a
énormément de charisme
là je me suis à un moment donné quand je
le regarde je dis oui ça va on voit
vraiment que la tension s'en va mais
après au premier abord non jeu c'était
moi je voudrais juste dire un petit rue
parce que je voudrais remercier amont à
mon papa de me regarder pendant
l'émission
merci merci papa merci moi j'aime pas
les missions elle va à l'encontre de ma
morale mais toi dire que vous m'avez
donné envie d'aimer ce programme mois
contrairement à moi j'adore vous n'êtes
pas du tout trouvé hautaine je vous ai
trouvé vrai je vous est tombé juste
parce que justement vous n'êtes pas dans
la séduction cabotine vous n'avez pas
d'étonnement on voit que vous êtes
complètement fragilisé vous êtes
complètement insécure ça ne savait pas
gérer ce machin là vous prenez un
ravioli ça correspond absolument pas ce
qu'il faut faire à ce moment là et moi
c'est ça qui m'a plu parce que j'ai
trouvé que ce moment était justement
extrêmement vrai est extrêmement
émouvant il faut savoir que cette
émission c'est pas comme une télé
réalité c'est une émission où on est
vraiment dans l'authenticité des gens
moi je n'ai maîtrisé mais alors je ne
maîtrisais rien heureusement d'ailleurs
c'est simple
ma journalistes d'ailleurs que j'aime
beaucoup mam a vraiment vraiment essayé
de canaliser durant le tournage parce
que parce que voilà on est des personnes
qui sont vraies c'est pas une émission
de buzz c'est vraiment dans
l'authenticité
j'ai 41 ans j'ai 41 ans ggp à 25 ans
j'ai pas 30 ans je sais ce que je veux
plus aller loin et votre boss les trucs
à princesse âgée le coût de ces monts le
coup de coeur là c'est terminé ça donc
une baisse que là moi je sens que lui je
sow qui il ya un délire il était bon
sens est ce que vous êtes pécho je ne
comprends rien
est ce que est ce que ya eu un
rapprochement physique
bah oui non uniquement cérébrale non
sans rigoler bah je rigole pas mais
convenez vous appris un peu une image
panoramique ya pas eu un bail non mais
on a 41 ans
bah on va pas non pas lorsque daniela 52
ans avait
je n'ai pas cinquante deux ans monsieur
raconté un wind pas encore bon comme le
papa merci bosser pour remercier ce que
vous et moi tout d'abord cécile ou alors
elle disait vous avez 41 ans oui alors
continuer jkr interne en amphi pas des
perles à un moment donné voilà la raison
mais c'est la vérité moi je veux dire
c'est naturel on est là avant tout on
est des êtres humains
après il ya eu il ya eu ce que vous
verrez après par la suite dans les
épisodes un déblocage de ma part ou ou
après j'ai réussi à esquiver cette
carapace etc etc ces barrières que
j'avais avec lui fallait bien sûr j'ai
eu le malheur scop dans un vrai mariage
non mais c'est pas non mais la nuit 9
oui c'est un vrai mariage
ouais non mais les gencives s'est fait
confirmer après quand même après
plusieurs jours parce que philippe il
sait pas qu'après ils vont partir vivre
ensemble un moment et confirmer ou pas
après le mariage avec sa mairie mais le
mariage me pardonnez moi vous le faites
à la mairie ou à l'église ou maintenance
à la mairie donc ça veut dire que vous
êtes vraiment marié tout à que vous avez
la possibilité ballard c'est ce qu'elle
est bien sûr j'aime parler de famille et
tous les goûts une semaine après les
vives orsenna peut pas nous dire si elle
a divorcé au mois mai dispute à moi il
paraît que m6 ne voulait pas que vous
veniez alors c'est pas que m6 ne voulait
pas que je vienne
c'est qu'il ya des certaines discorde
voilà d'après ce que j'ai compris en
même temps moi c'est un monde qui m'est
complètement étranger et je ne suis pas
rentré dans les détails et à savoir du
pourquoi du comment on m'a déconseillé
de venir à cette émission parce que
c'est en fait la cage aux lions voilà
c'est nous et ne nous parlait de moi
vous êtes le chef des looks en fait
ouais et douadi quoi ils vont vous
demander d'être humain en général
en général je parle pas que maman des
années gentil avec vous non bas jusqu'à
maintenant ils savent a alors là ça
démarre bien alors cécile justesse que
vous êtes contente de de l'aventuré si
c'était à refaire je le ferais vraiment
gg non seulement compris qu'il fallait
que je je je je me laisse la chance
d'être une femme
enfin à 41 ans et de pas qu'être maman
mais j'ai appris beaucoup sur la
relation que j'ai avec ma fille m'a dit
ça à nice à nador ouais et
ça fait un mois que j'ai pas mis tout ça
pour ça que j'ai appelé nu et donc voilà
j'ai appris beaucoup sur ma fille noma
relation qui est très fusionnelle et en
même temps très toxique entre guillemets
avec ma fille et sur la jante une femme
belle à 18 ans à 18 ans elle était elle
arrivée là là là ou pas alors elle a
validé alain ouais parce qu'elle m'a dit
qui me ressemblait avec un petit peu
plus de poils d'accord mais mais sinon
oui elle est la valider complètement à
l'abri à voile à l aile trophée me tiens
moi chez moi je manie d'alain je trouve
ben ali est quelqu'un de très bons alain
est quelqu'un avec énormément de valeur
je peux vous dire un truc
oui moi je vois je je peux à jodie je
dis ce que je pense je dis à tes
lecteurs j'ai dis toujours ce que je
pense je kiffe alain mais je vous sens
pas love 2 ans d'alain amoureuse mais je
ne sens que j'ai plus un ami que à ma
rue on ne devra se baser sur sur dix
minutes de visionnage sur un nouveau jeu
le monde si j'ai des paillettes dans les
yeux non non aucune payet non moi je le
sens je sens qu'il va y avoir ça va se
terminer cette affaire après on peut pas
nous dire et je veux même pas savoir
parce que je n'ai pas envie d'avoir j'ai
envie de regarder les démissions et de
qui fait des émissions mais je la sens
pas la faire je sens que là et c'est
fini mais je vous demande pas de réponse
c'est très gentil merci gilles verdez je
voudrais vous poser la question sur la
scène qui a tant fait parler sur les
réseaux qui est celle du mariage au
moment où alain regarde notre fille est
ce qu'on l'a cette scène dodine parce
qu'ils employaient les animaux nous
parler pendant deux heures ce matin en
réunion mais je suis sûr qu'ils n'ont
pas pris c'est c'est comme ça qu'on
reconnaît les voilà il regarde à ce
moment là alain regarde la fille de
cécile a mis sa génie est dit si votre
maman est aussi jolie que vous voilà et
cette scène a fait réagir parce que la
manière dont ils regardent votre fille
vu de l'extérieur nous on se dit que
c'est un regard quand même de séduction
la voix lui dit avant qu'il aime les
femmes plus jeunes madame et comment
vous avez vécu ça sur rien et c'est à
dire ça énorme et ça peut plus réagir
oui oui si je peux me permets pas déçu
permettez la manière dont ça a été
août est oui là alain m
les femmes légèrement plus jeune que lui
38 à 38 ans n'est pas quelqu'un qui aime
les gamines de 20 ans alain a énormément
de respect pour ma fille et dont il a
dit si la mer est aussi belle que la
fifa l'a rassuré mais il n'était pas du
tout dans une alliance d'une d'entamer
les missions d'éducation chose
d'accord je vous assure énormément de
personnes sur les réseaux qui qui qui
qui qui donnent une mauvaise image à la
mélange oui oui oui
nicolas je suis pas d'accord parce que
effectivement je rejoins gym est
abandonnée même il dit ah tiens vous
êtes des amis vous êtes des amis a donc
et alyssa répond non je suis sa fille
met donc la laddh cuir rebondit donc il
ya quand même moi j'étais un peu jazz
j'adore cette émission mais j'étais
j'étais mal à l'aise et justement je me
demande est ce que vous allez ressentir
ailleurs dans le programme hier parce
que je trouvais que ça pouvait mais
cécile moi je prends beaucoup de recul
maladie sur les commentaires des
internautes sur comment
on peut percevoir la chose la seule
chose qui peut m'atteindre c'est ma
fille comme voilà pour le faible c'est
ma fille maintenant j'ai beaucoup
influencé castaldi a à bamako on va le
faire mais par contre j'ai beaucoup à
nice a au téléphone d'ailleurs elle va
revenir votre vivre à la maison parce
que voilà j'ai besoin aussi de la
protéger et appartements où ma fille me
dit non maman savate inquiète pas c'est
bon on peut dire n'importe quoi
par contre il faut aussi et ça c'est
très important
savoir que alain est papa de deux
enfants
d'accord mais que certains réactions
concernant cette attitude qui pour moi à
la mairie ne m'a absolument pas choqué
peu leur thé juste deux dernières
questions est ce que vous êtes heureuse
oui tron vous êtes amoureuse merci